Chris, so about this price for this series of training courses, 4,200.
Unfortunately, we can't afford that.
Is there any way you could come down a little bit?
Well, if you book several courses in advance...
...then I could reduce the price by 45 dollars per course,...
...which would save us 180 dollars.
So, I could come down to 4,020.
How about that?
I really can only afford 2,800 dollars on this course,...
...but if you did some tailoring to our company,...
...I'm sure that I can convince my boss to pay 3,200.
Yeah, I can't come down to 3,200,...
...but what I'm thinking is, if you kept the numbers per course to 12 people or fewer,...
...then I could bring it down from 4,020 to 3,840.
How about that?
It's still a little bit high,...
...but maybe you could write some specific role plays for our company...
...that we could use internally after the program.
Yeah.
And if you could include a copy of the Happiness book, which I hear is brilliant,...
...we could do an extra five dollars a head...
...and I think that would bring us to 3,650, which is what we can afford.
Thirty-six fifty, I tell you what, if we could make the third day a half day rather than a full day,...
...that would be useful to me...
...and I could still make sure we covered all the material you need covered.
So, if we could do that, then I could come down to your figure of 3,650.
Perfect! All right, you got yourself a deal.
Great!
Thank you.